hi everyone hey all done was having a
good i/o so thanks for coming here so
let's get start with this session so a
session today is all about bringing
Android apps over to Android TV so my
name is Wayne Piekarski I'm a developer
advocate at Google and I work in areas
like TV and cast in the living room and
wearables and I might my goal is to you
know communicate information about these
products to developers but also to talk
to you more and find out about what your
needs are and feed them back to the
product teams so I'm Ryan I'm a
developer programs engineer at Google
and I build things for you guys you
developers you know things like tools
API client libraries and samples just to
make your lives more productive all
right so today we're going to assume
that you have some knowledge about
Android development because the goal is
is we're gonna teach you how to take
your apps and how to get them working on
Android TV so what's the motivation for
this talk well I've been talking lots of
developers out there and I say hey have
you done an afro TV before and they're
like ah you know I don't think this is
something I can do it's too much work or
whatever and it turns out that most
developers aren't fully aware of how
similar Android TV is to Android itself
so I thought wouldn't it be great if we
did a talk about this and to show you
the small steps that are needed to get
your app onto the big screen so if
developers aren't doing this why is this
a problem
well right now there are millions of
Android TV devices that are activated
out there right now and the number keeps
going up every day you can buy TVs with
Android TV included you can buy little
set-top boxes that include Android TV as
well and they're really cheap and
affordable and a lot of people have
these devices in their living rooms now
and these customers are looking for apps
to use on their devices so the important
thing here is that if you go to an
Android TV device and start up Google
Play not every app in the Play Store
will appear on your device immediately
it turns out as a developer you actually
need to take a few small steps and tell
Google Play that your app is ready for
TV and then it'll make your app
available so that's what we're going to
talk about today we're going to show you
how to do this and the good news is that
Android TV is really easy to develop for
so to quote my very famous colleague
Ryan here it's just Android and so it
uses the same SDKs the same tools that
you're familiar with same Android studio
and the same emulator tools so you can
get started really easy if you're
familiar with Android right now and so
the basics are you tweak your manifest
file check a box in Google Play and your
apps ready so that's the really cool
thing about it that's what we're going
to talk about today so the other thing
is that you can actually make a single
APK that you upload to Google Play that
supports both TV and phone that sounds
similar these things up so the first
thing with this talk that I wanted to
sort of point out is that a lot of
people think well Android TV is only
useful for watching TV shows and movies
but I really think there's so much more
possibilities for what you can do rather
than just those things so imagine you
could browse photos and artwork you
could look at restaurant menus or houses
that you're looking to buy or exploring
maps or 3d models or playing computer
games so there's a whole bunch of
possibilities that really make the
possibilities endless and so Android TV
really breaks down the possibilities of
what we thought TV could be used for
into so much more other things and the
other thing is that Android TV is the
largest screen in your house every house
has this massive screen that's in the
living room in the center of the house
and so it has huge possibilities for
what you can do with it and so that's
what we're trying to encourage today is
for developers to think of new platforms
and new ways of taking their apps and
getting them out to consumers out there
so today we're gonna help you redefine
what a living room experience could be
and really create amazing apps so I
enough two right now and he's going to
go through some more of the steps of how
to do this
Thanks so the first step in bringing
your app to Android TV is you're going
to need to add a TV banner this banner
is going to provide the launch point for
your app on the Android TV launch screen
so here's an example banner that I've
taken directly from our sample app which
is available on github
here is our sample banner alongside some
official Android TV apps this is what it
would appear like on the Android TV
launcher itself so there are a couple
requirements that we would like you to
follow when you're creating your TV
banner the first is that the banner
should be 320 by 180 pixels that's
because Android TV this is the size that
it's going to display it at and if you
make your banner any other size it's
just gonna stretch it and skew it in a
way that you wouldn't really like the
second is that your app name should
appear readable in the banner itself and
the reason for this is on Android TV the
name of your app doesn't actually appear
below the banner and so we ask that you
put it inside the banner itself so that
your users can understand what app
they're clicking on when they open yours
so it's super simple to add it takes a
single line in your manifest I'm sure
you're familiar with this in your
application tag just add Android banner
attribute and pointed at your drawable
resource super easy right um so if you
did all this and you tried to run your
app nothing would actually happen just
setting this banner doesn't get your app
running on android TV and so next I'm
just gonna talk about how you would
declare the activity to launch when you
click on the banner so let's jump into
it so here's an activity this may be
your main activity in your Android
manifest and you have an existing intent
filter there with the action main and
the category launcher so here which it's
going to add a second intent shelter to
your existing activity with the category
Leanback launcher the reason that we
actually separate launcher and Leanback
launcher is because our best practices
is that you're going to create your own
TV specific UI and layouts eventually
however for the purpose of this talk
we're just going to say why not get
started throw it in your existing
activity and see how much it works like
I said earlier it's just Android so
you'd be surprised by how much works
right out of the box the next big
difference on android TV is the TV
hardware itself so mobile devices you
know they can make phone calls they can
take photo
they use NFC they have touchscreens TVs
don't have any of these things at least
like my TV doesn't have a touchscreen
and so for these reasons we actually
need to tell Android that these features
that we may have come to expect on a TV
or on a phone will not be available on a
TV so the way that we do this is through
our users feature tag and you guys I'm
sure are all familiar with this you
declare the hardware features that you
would like to use in your app manifest
and this is probably fine you know for
phones and tablets it's gonna
automatically set required a true
however for Android TV and for TV
Hardware specifically this Hardware
might not be available on TVs and so we
need to update that to required false so
that so that the TV itself knows that
hey I can still operate without this
hardware requirement so one gotcha
actually is that the touchscreen
Hardware requirement is by default
required true even if you don't declare
that you need it and so we actually need
to take this snippet that you see here
and add it directly right into your
Android manifest
so another gotcha is that some
permissions actually if you're if you
asked for like say a record audio
permission it's actually gonna imply
this Hardware requirement for a
microphone and this makes sense right
you want to be able to record some audio
so you're gonna need a microphone but
the you might not actually declare the
uses feature itself and so what we what
we have to do to get around this is just
go into your Android manifest declare
uses feature tag and set required to
false okay so this is the most important
part about bringing your app to Android
TV this is the UI navigation and
controls so with no touchscreen
available on TVs we have to rely on
these minimal controls and this is
brings us to the d-pad so the d-pad
which also stands for directional pad is
the de-facto way to navigate on Android
TV
now this d-pad is not an entirely new
idea some of the first phones actually
use d-pad for navigation and when we say
navigation what we're really talking
about here is this intuitive change of
focus touchscreens have revolutionized
our ability to you know tell our
interfaces when I tap here I want you to
focus and take action at that specific
point however on TVs we don't have this
same luxury because there's no
touchscreen available so in order to
focus what we need to do is
progressively shift our focus from
element to element through our UI until
we get to the one that we want and on
Android there are a number of different
ways that focus is handled and
manipulated and so I'm gonna discuss
each one of these briefly so first thing
that you need to know about Android
focus on Android is this attribute
called focusable and I'm sure you're all
familiar with this in simple terms
though on Android TV your users are
going to be using a remote so on with
any element that you want them to
interact with they the element itself
should be focused upon and to do that
all we do is we set this focusable
attribute to be true so as an example
use case here where you may be creating
some custom playback layout and it has a
play/pause button here which we've
represented with an image view and
you're going to want to be able to
navigate to that play pause button so
that you can eventually click it so all
we do is we just set focusable to true
now one thing to keep in mind here a
little bit of a gotcha is that some
views aren't they don't set focusable to
be true by default image view is one of
these so in this case we have to set it
explicitly to true great so now we can
focus and select our play button but
what if we want to say press right on
the d-pad and have it focus on the
fast-forward button or press left and
have it focus on the rewind button so we
use these two other attributes next
focus right and next focus left so by
setting these two attributes as shown
here
now androids going to switch the focus
automatically when you press those
buttons on the d-pad so there may be
other times where you want to you know
create your views directly in Java code
and so specifying this focus in the XML
is not going to be available to you for
example you may be generating a lot of
views like a grid shown here and you're
not going to necessarily be able to
declare exactly what I should be
focusing on at that specific point so we
need some way to ask Android to change
this focus and we do that through this
request focus method which is available
on the view class so request focus just
does exactly that it requests it asks
Android to bring that view into focus if
it is focusable and that's a key point
if it's focusable so be sure to make
make sure that that view is focusable
set to true before you request focus or
else it won't do anything so the last
thing that I'd like to discuss here
about the d-pad is what if you want to
take some arbitrary actions when any key
is pressed so to do this we're gonna
override the activities on keydown
method this method fires when any key is
pressed that isn't already handled by
one of these views inside of your
activity so an example here is that you
could combine this on this on T down
with requests focus to change focus when
any key is pressed or a really common
use case is if I press play pause button
on the remote it's going to play I'm
gonna play or pause my video or if
you're making a game like I'm showing
here maybe when you press the write
d-pad button you're going to move your
player to the right
okay so Brian talked you through a
little bit about focus and moving things
around and so forth now we're going to
talk a bit about the screen so it turns
out with televisions nowadays they don't
quite operate in the same way that we
would expect you would think that if
you've got a 1080 HDMI signal and you
feed it through to a screen that you
would get a one-to-one mapping it turns
out that's not quite the case so I'm
going to talk a little bit about
something called overscan protection
so if we actually go back in time back
in the days of analog TV there were
these edges on the screen that we're not
used and TV stations actually used to
embed little signalling and bits of data
and things like that in that area that
wasn't displayed by the television it
turns out then we move to HD that stuff
still happened and so a lot of TV
manufacturers will actually take a TV
image and they'll chop off the edges and
then stretch the image slightly so it
fits the screen so what this means is
that you don't get a one-to-one mapping
and some of the pixels on the edge
actually get chopped off so you can
disable this on some televisions there's
overscan or some other feature like that
that you can remove with the remote but
a lot of users don't know how to do it
so you need to be aware of the fact that
there are some people out there who are
not going to see the edges of the screen
of your app and so we need to go about
dealing with that somehow and so if we
look at this diagram here you can see
that we have our 1080p overall display
and we've also shown it in terms of DPS
which is device pixels and then you can
show the areas that are not included and
we have a guideline which is that you
should roughly stick to not using the
outer 5% of the image and that's usually
a safe thing so if we look here you can
see we've got some UI elements and we've
got the edges protected so that we don't
use them so once again a 5 percent outer
area is something that you should
reserve that your app shouldn't put
anything important in now if you have a
background image that's okay if that
gets cropped because it's just that
probably the interesting part is in the
center of the screen so background
images can get cropped but important
pieces of text labels any kind of
important information like that you've
got to make sure that you keep it out of
that region and so here we have a custom
layout XML that we're showing we've got
to relative layouts and the inner
relative layout if you look at it is
padded with the 5% margin so you can see
we're setting margin top bottom left and
right and we've set DP values that
represent that margin and anything we
put inside that inner relative layout
will not be cropped off by the
television for any reason anything else
that you don't care about like the
background image we talked about earlier
you can put that in the outer
relativelayout at the top and that will
possibly be cropped by the television so
this is pretty easy to implement and
it's not really a huge deal but it's
just something you got to keep in mind
so that you make sure it works for all
users next not every one programs their
Android TV apps using the Android IV
api's directly so there's actually a
cross-platform gaming engine called
unity that's quite popular amongst game
developers and so the good news for
unity developers is that it actually
supports Android TV out of the box so
unity has support for the d-pad so all
that stuff Ryan talked about with
handling the controls that's already
dealt with for you and it deals with all
the manifest tweaks and over scanning
and making sure that everything's done
right so there's actually a collab that
we've prepared for Android TV so if you
go behind this auditorium there is a
collab area where you can go and sit
down and try out code and mess around we
have a code lab for unity there as well
that you can give a try
so that's the nice thing is that a lot
of these extra tools and so forth
support Android TV out of the box as
well so if you've got a game that does
3d and OpenGL and all that it just works
so now we're going to ryan to talk more
about the Leanback library which is a
very popular way of implementing really
nice TV you eyes thanks rain so you know
at Google we're trying to make your
lives easier as developers and we know
that you don't really want to implement
all this stuff yourself and so to help
out we created the Leanback library it
has a great selection of UI components
that are specifically designed for
Android TV and these components come
with support for d-pad as well as
overscan protection already baked right
in so now I'm gonna step through some of
these components and and explain why you
may consider using this library so the
first component here that I want to
discuss is this browse fragment the
Browse fragment is good for good for
well browsing right it allows you to
showcase all of your content in one
place and so one of the best places to
use the Browse fragment is when
immediately when the user opens this app
so here's an example of it being used in
practice this is what it looks like
being run in our Leanback sample live
app available on github and you can see
here that there's a sidebar with some
header rows and a main grid of content
so if you jump into a category by
pressing right on the d-pad you can see
a more detailed view of this content
here we show some thumbnail images and
title and category these can be
basically whatever you want you could
display a rating for your content you
could display a price anything that you
can imagine um so if you select on one
of these cards then that brings us into
another fragment that we call the
details fragment so the details fragment
prevent presents all of the details for
a specific piece of content it allows
your users to take certain actions
anything that you can imagine like
watching renting buying this piece of
content so again here it is in practice
and you can customize of course all
these colors text buttons to provide a
personalized experience specific to that
piece of content so in this case with
our new dad video we can click watch
trailer and then we get into another
fragment that we call the playback
overlay fragment so this provides a
large customized controls that overlay
on top of the media itself it also
provides an at-a-glance view of what's
currently playing so again here it is in
practice it has a primary row which
provides things like play pause rewind
fast-forward next video previous video
as well as the secondary row such as
closed captioning picture in picture
here I'm showing some thumbs-up
thumbs-down and some repeat
functionality and then hidden at the
bottom there is a wreath related videos
row this is just a place that you can
place you know related content to
whatever is currently playing and so
this could be where you recommend the
next video to play for your user so if
the users can't find this you know next
great piece of content to absorb in this
related video list then you know maybe
search is the next best thing and you
know being Google we want to provide a
great search
experience and so we've added the search
fragment to the Leanback library and so
here again is it in practice and we're
searching for the word search and I
think the best feature of this whole
search fragment is speech recognition
capability so you can use the microphone
which is baked right into the Nexus
player remote to speak whatever you want
and have it have it immediately fill in
the field so in addition to in-app
search we you can also integrate with
this universal search so this is when a
user searches from the main TV launcher
for some related content and that will
get surface automatically by the Android
system so you can imagine you get home
you turn on the TV and you search funny
movies if your app has some funny movies
you're gonna want to surface that to the
user and so to integrate with search
there's just a few things that you need
to do the first is implementing a
content provider and you might already
have one of these maybe you're already
using one for your in-app search and so
you can see our documentation for all
the specific roads that we support but
the key thing here is that the provider
that you create you should set this
attribute exported true so that Android
has access to it and can query it when a
universal search is made and then the
next thing is this searchable XML and
again you might already have one of
these implemented in your app already
and so what you need to do here is just
set this include in global search
attribute to true so that Android again
can access this content so even before
search your app might actually have a
good idea of what the user wants to see
next and so Android TV has this powerful
way that we liked it that we can help
which we call recommendations
so this recommendations bar is featured
front and center as soon as the user
opens up their Android TV Android goes
through app each app and asks hey do you
have any recommendations that you'd like
me to present to the user and so it
takes all of these from each app and it
merges them together and so when a user
clicks
on a recommendation which would appear
in this bar the the it'll immediately
open your app to that piece of content
so here are a few recommendations on
well what you may want to recommend to
your users
the first is continuation content you
know a good example is the next episode
in a series as well as new content
things like new episodes or a new series
altogether as well as popular or
trending content and then related
content this is things like based off
the users viewing history or behavior
and so all of these UI in fragments that
we've shown you today they're available
through the Leanback and recommendation
support libraries which if you're using
Android studio which we highly recommend
you might be familiar with Gradle of
course we support the these Gradle
dependencies and so you just drop these
two you drop these two lines into your
build.gradle and Gradle will handle
everything else wait so one common thing
I hear from developers when they're
asking about Android TV is they're like
oh hey you know I can't develop for
Android TV because I don't have a device
on my desk and so while it's nice to
have a device you don't actually need
one because the emulator is actually
available to help you do your testing so
a lot of people think the emulator also
isn't good enough but it turns out the
emulator in Android studio is actually
really good and so for Android TV we've
done a lot of work in improving its
performance and so it's actually really
nice to use this for development and so
what we're gonna do now is we're going
to show you a quick little demo so
they're gonna bring it up on the screen
there this is Ryan's laptop running the
emulator right now and so this emulator
here is the x86 variant so it's very
important that you run x86 when you're
on an x86 laptop so that it doesn't have
to emulate everything completely and
it's also important that you have the
Haxton driver as well so we can see here
is Ryan's running the sample that I'll
give you the link to later but the
sample has a series of video clips and
he's browsing around fragments and so do
you want to fire up a video run so this
here shows video playback happening so
it's streaming the video
it's decoding it playing it back within
the emulator so as you can see here it's
very performant its decoding the video
in real time on his laptop and so the
emulator is quite useful also if we look
on the right of the screen there is the
extended controls so an Android TV has
its own remote with left/right up/down
but it also has back pause play and so
forth all of those controls are
available on the emulator as well so you
can simulate every single button press
and check that your code has all the
right d-pad support and things like that
because not every button necessarily is
mapped to the keys so the great thing is
that the simulator does all of the
buttons that are available and regular
devices and you don't need to purchase a
physical Android TV device so this is
pretty cool and it's definitely if
you're interested in doing this you
should grab the sample 5 D emulator try
it out and then when you're ready you
can publish it and your app will work
really well on real devices too so once
you've built your app so we've gone
through all the different little
manifest tags and things like that we're
now at the point where we need to talk
about publishing your app to Google Play
so we have the Wii back we can go back
are you ever gets it back from the ok
great things so now we're going to talk
about how to get your app and publish it
to the console so if we go to this slide
here you can see a screenshot showing
what the developer console looks like so
this is the same place where you upload
your regular apks that you're uploading
from mobile and there is an option in
device categories where it says Android
TV and if you look right at the bottom
there there's a checkbox that says
distribute your app to Android TV so by
default that box is not checked so if
you want your app to be visible on TV
devices you have to check that box as
well that then declares to the play that
your app is ready for TV and there is a
few little conditions there and you can
click on that learn more link to find
out more about what the requirements are
so you submit your app it gets approved
and then after that it'll then be
available for people to find on Android
TV devices and then they can go to the
Play and then they can search for your
app
by speaking or typing it in and then
they can install it just like they would
on a phone and updates are rolled out in
the same way and everything like that so
it's a pretty easy and painless
experience and as I said earlier you can
either have a single apk that contains
all of the resources and activities for
both phone and TV or you can have
separate apks where one has the
resources and everything for TV and the
other one has for phone what you do is
going to be dependent on your target
market is and how concerned you are
about download sizes and also how much
difference there is between the TV and
the phone app if there's no differences
in the resources you can just do a
single apk so we've gone through some
guidelines in this talk the guidelines
are actually referenced in the
documentation and there's actually a
link here on developer.android.com which
has a complete checklist of all of the
things that are important to get your
app approved to be distributed on Google
Play now it's important that you get
your app approved because if it's
rejected it won't be visible so it's
very important that you actually think
carefully about each of the guidelines
to minimize the amount of time it takes
for you to get it on the on Google Play
so let's quickly walk through them and
summarize quickly what they are so Ryan
mentioned earlier you need to have a
Leanback launcher in your Android
manifest this declares that your app is
ready for TV and it says what the
activity is going to be when someone
clicks on your app to start it up you
need a banner image that's 320 by 180 at
xhdpi resolution if you don't use that
resolution
it'll be resized for you you need to
eliminate requirements for any
unsupported hardware remember TVs don't
have touch screens so you need to have
touch screen equals false and any other
requirements you have like if your app
uses GPS you're gonna have to set that
to false as well and make sure that if
your code is doing something like
grabbing location check for errors to
make sure that you don't accidentally
fail and throw an exception so as part
of the new transition to the new
permission model apps have to check a
lot more for these things
the same kind of thing here you've got
to make sure you don't expect a device
to be available when it's not next thing
ensure any permissions you add don't add
hardware requirements as well so
permissions like record audio that rain
showed earlier also have requirements
that you have to manually set to
required equals false next you can't
assume that your app is running on a
portrait device like a phone runs as a
portrait orientation and some apps lock
themselves so they don't run in
landscape mode it's very important
because the TV is a landscape device
that your resources are configured
correctly for screens like that next you
really need to think about viewing
everything from a distance so this is no
longer something that you're running
very close to your face it's running on
a screen that's very far away in
someone's living room so you really need
to think of large fonts and easily easy
to read text and large images and you
should test it so try to step back from
the screen and check that it's actually
readable from a distance like that you
know some people have poor vision
they're not going to be able to read
super tiny writing like that next make
sure you think about overscan we talked
about that before make sure you don't
put anything important within the outer
5% of your screen and so lastly think
about implementing the Leanback user
interface so if you've got an app that's
like a game you probably don't need to
but if you're building some kind of
browsing something that goes through
media or food or pictures or photos make
sure that if you want to really make it
integrate into the Android TV experience
that you use the Leanback library
because the Leanback gives a consistent
UI across the whole device that it'll
look the same between other apps and
also with the Android TV system itself
so those are the guidelines and that
link up there is available in the
documentation you should definitely look
through them when you're getting ready
to publish your app so that was a really
quick overview of how to bring your app
over to Android TV so I hope you found
it inspiring and it sort of gave you
some ideas as to how to think about
taking your app and what would be
involved in making the change it's not
really hard to do there's just a few
little things so how do we get started
with this well the first thing is the
talks being recorded so if you want to
review everything later on you'll be
able to go back and go through
everything but we also have a lot of
other great resources which are shown on
this slide here so the first thing we
have is the documentation site so on
developer.android.com/design
give an overview and sort of summarize
some of the things we've said today and
then we also have the Leanback sample so
it's on github and the google samples
it's called android TV lean back and
that demo that ryan showed earlier is
that sample there so you can play with
it see how the video stream see how it
works for you and it's a really great
way to sort of see how a well built app
works and you could probably tear it
apart and put your own code in there and
so forth the next thing I mentioned we
have the code labs in the other area
where you can go over there and you can
try out you can sit down play with some
devices and there are actually engineers
on staff there who can help answer your
questions as well and we also have the
sandbox so there is an area over there
with these large metal box crate things
that we have an area showing TV and cast
devices feel free to come by there and
we have people who work on the actual
Android TV team ready to answer
questions there as well and also people
like me and Ryan will be there too so
we're getting to the end of the day so
it's not too much time left but please
do come by after the talk and come have
a chat with us because the whole point
of Google i/o is we want to share
information with people and get
information from developers if you've
tried to do Android TV and something
didn't work out for you come and tell us
what happens so that we can think about
it maybe come up with a solution for you
and finally for people who can't come
here or for later we have a great
developer community on Google+ so the
link is GGO Android TV dev and it's a
great place where we post articles about
what's coming up what's new and also
it's a place where you can ask questions
and chat with other developers and
definitely I recommend you follow us
because I post a lot of articles about
TV but also I do wearables and auto and
all these other things and there's a lot
of commonality between the platforms
that Google offers and so if you've got
a phone app you should consider TV and
auto and wearables because there's are
all new exciting platforms where users
are waiting for really cool and exciting
apps thank you very much for coming and
thank you a lot
you